vielleicht kommt oder vielleicht auch
nicht
ja sie haben das ja gerade schon schön
erläutert die gasumlage die versteht
hier im Parlament glaube ich auch keiner
mehr so richtig also der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ist jetzt der
Meinung dass das vielleicht doch nicht
der richtige Weg ist die gasumlage ist
Murks das hat heute morgen noch mal der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
cdu/csu Herr frei gesagt die cdu/csu
wird die Abschaffung der gasumlage am
Donnerstag auch noch mal in den
Bundestag einbringen und wenn das wieder
abgelehnt werden sollte wird man es in
der kommenden Sitzungswoche wieder
einbringen fünf Wochen haben wir vor uns
davon vier Sitzungswochen und in diesen
vier Sitzungswochen will die Ampel das
dritte entlastungsgesetz also die
einzelnen Gesetze die diese Entlastung
bringen durch den Deutschen Bundestag
bringen unter anderem auch das Gesetz
für gasumlage da soll die mehrere
umlagesteuer
reduziert werden das kommt am Donnerstag
in den Parlament wenn es bis dahin noch
kommt oder man einigt sich vorher doch
noch auf einen anderen Weg das ist nach
dem was ich bislang von den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden vor ihrer Sitzung
gehört habe nicht mehr ganz so klar zu
sagen die Bundesregierung arbeitet zwar
an einer Verbesserung des Gesetzes da
ist unter anderem gesagt worden die
gasumlage dürfen nur noch
energiebetreiber bekommen die keinen
Gewinn machen logisch das Problem war ja
dass nach dem ursprünglichen Gesetz auch
solche
energiebetreiber die gasumlage von 2,4
Cent bekommen hätten die gar keine
Verluste gemacht haben und das geht
natürlich nicht schlecht gemacht dieses
Gesetz handwerklich das kritisiert die
Opposition schon seit langer Zeit und
jetzt wie gesagt kommt auch Robert
Habeck ins Grübeln den 15 Milliarden hat
uniper schon von Steuergeldern bekommen
vier Milliarden ist jetzt die
Nachforderung und die Stadtwerke echzen
und Stöhnen wie überhaupt alle Bürger
natürlich unter den steigenden Preisen
und die Frage ist wie kann der Staat
sicherstellen dass diese Preise nicht
explodieren und deswegen jetzt die
erneute Diskussion denn Rober hat
argumentiert wenn es dann letztlich doch
in eine Verstaatlichung läuft dann ist
das juristisch wohl nicht mehr haltbar
und wir haben ja gerade schon aus dem
Studio gehört bei Juniper ist das gar
nicht so einfach denn der finnische
Staat dem gehört ja 40 Prozent dieses
Konzerns also sehr komplizierte Materie
wollen wir sehen was der Oppositionschef
Friedrich Merz dazu zu sagen hat kommen
zu unserem kurzen vor der gleich
beginnenden Fraktionssitzung
wir treten zusammen heute Nachmittag zu
einem Zeitpunkt zu dem in Deutschland
die Sorgen um die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung sowohl in den privaten
Haushalten als auch in den Unternehmen
rapide zunehmen wir sehen nicht nur in
Ostdeutschland aber vor allem in
Ostdeutschland
zunehmende Proteste in der Bevölkerung
gegen die Unentschlossenheit der
Bundesregierung in Sachen
Inflationsrate
Energieversorgung Schutz der privaten
Haushalte und auch Schutz der kleinen
und mittleren Unternehmen
wir werden heute Nachmittag ausführlich
über unsere Antworten noch einmal
beraten die wir geben wollen an die
Bevölkerung in Sachen Inflationsrate in
Sachen
Versorgung mit Energie und in Sachen
Sicherheit für die kleinen und mittleren
Unternehmen die Lage ist in höchstem
Maße besorgniserregend wir steuern auf
einen sehr schwierigen herbst- und
Winter zu und wir hätten eigentlich
erwartet dass die Bundesregierung die
Sommerferien nutzt um sich vorzubereiten
auf eine solche Lage die seit mehreren
Wochen absehbar ist wir befinden uns
jetzt im sechsten Monat dieses
schrecklichen Krieges die Konsequenzen
für die Energieversorgung liegen seit
Wochen auf dem Tisch und wir sehen eine
sich um fast alle Themen
streitende Regierung das beginnt bei der
gasumlage sie wissen dass wir den Antrag
gestellt haben und wir werden in diese
Woche noch einmal stellen sie
abzuschaffen das geht weiter über das
Hochfahren der Kohlekraftwerke
Steinkohle und Braunkohle die Zusagen
des Bundeswirtschaftsministers aus dem
Sommer die ist jetzt unverzüglich zu tun
werden nur teilweise eingehalten zum
Teil warten die Kraftwerke bis heute auf
die Betriebsgenehmigung und dies gilt
nicht zuletzt für die weitere Nutzung
der Kernenergie wir wiederholen unseren
Vorschlag die drei noch am Netz
befindlichen Kernkraftwerke Isa 2
Neckarwestheim und Emsland
weiterlaufen zu lassen die Möglichkeiten
dazu sind in jeder Hinsicht gegeben
personell
sicherheitstechnisch und auch rechtlich
wenden eine Änderung des Atomgesetzes so
schnell wie möglich auf den Weg gebracht
wird
wir haben uns entschlossen in der
Fraktionssitzung in der
fraktionsvorstandssitzung gestern dass
wir der Fraktion heute einen
ausgearbeiteten Gesetzentwurf zur
Änderung des Atomgesetzes vorschlagen
der eine Laufzeitverlängerung bis zum
31.12.2024
rechtlich ermöglicht das schließt ein
die Genehmigung dann auch neue
Brennstäbe für diese drei Kernkraftwerke
zu bestellen so dass wir dann einen
sicheren Weiterbetrieb der drei
Kernkraftwerke für die nächsten zwei
Jahre gewährleisten könnten und damit
die Stromversorgung von 10 Millionen
Haushalten in Deutschland gewährleistet
werden könnte ich kann ihnen berichten
dass aus unserem Fraktionsvorstand aber
auch aus den Wahlkreisen der Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zunehmend wirklich wütendes
Unverständnis über die mangelnde
Handlungsfähigkeit der Bundesregierung
kommt
wir werden mit Berichten konfrontiert
über
insolvenzgefährdete Unternehmen aber
auch über vollkommen verzweifelte
private Haushalte insbesondere aber bei
weitem nicht nur von älteren Menschen
die jetzt die Vorauszahlungsbescheide
bekommen für ihre Gas- und
Stromrechnungen die sie einfach nicht
mehr bezahlen können es ist ein Skandal
dass die deutsche Regierung bis zum
heutigen Tag keine abschließenden
Antworten hat auf diese ernsten Sorgen
der Bevölkerung der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
wir werden in dieser Woche verschiedene
Diskussionen im Parlament darüber haben
wir werden über das Atomgesetz sprechen
wir werden über die Energieversorgung
sprechen wir werden auch über die
Inflationsrate sprechen und hoffen dass
die Bundesregierung nun endlich in
dieser Sitzungswoche zu Entscheidungen
kommt wir können glaube ich alle
erwarten dass die Bundesregierung jetzt
ihren Streit beiseite legt dass der
Bundeskanzler seiner
Führungsverantwortung gerecht wird und
dafür sorgt dass diese Koalition in den
wesentlichen Fragen der
Wirtschaftspolitik und der
Energiepolitik handlungsfähig wird ich
will es nicht versäumen heute auf einen
Sachverhalt hinzuweisen der mit diesen
ganzen Themen gar nichts zu tun hat der
aber gleichwohl uns in den nächsten
Wochen politisch beschäftigen wird sie
werden vermutlich alle mitbekommen haben
dass der Europäische Gerichtshof heute
in Sachen Vorratsdatenspeicherung eine
weitere Entscheidung getroffen hat es
wird aber bleiben dass die sogenannte
Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Deutschland
mit europäischem Recht nicht vereinbar
ist es gibt ein großes aber der
Europäische Gerichtshof hat aus erlaubt
dass die Speicherung von IP-Adressen in
Fällen von schwersten Straftaten
zulässig bleibt ich appelliere an die
Bundesregierung diese Möglichkeit diese
rechtliche Möglichkeit der Speicherung
von IP-Adressen zu nutzen und dafür zu
sorgen dass dieses Mittel bei der
Untersuchung und Strafverfolgung von
schwersten Straftaten auch angewendet
werden kann ich sage das heute am
Weltkindertag und füge deshalb in diesem
Zusammenhang hinzu es geht auch aber
nicht nur es geht auch um die Verfolgung
schwerster Straftaten gegen Kinder gegen
Kindesmissbrauch in unserer Gesellschaft
und wir haben alle in den letzten Jahren
lernen müssen dass es offensichtlich
eine sehr sehr große Zahl von solchen
Fällen gibt jeden Tag jede Woche jeden
Monat Kinder kleinste Kinder Neugeborene
Opfer von sexuell motivierten Straftaten
sind diese Straftaten werden dann
anschließend in Filmen und in Fotos auch
noch großflächig verteilt das sind
Straftaten wie man sie in einer
zivilisierten Gesellschaft sich kaum
schwerer vorstellen kann und gerade
heute am Weltkindertag möchte ich an die
Bundesregierung appellieren
klarzustellen dass sie bereit ist so wie
übrigens die bundesinnenministerin des
auch gesagt hat leider wieder einmal
gegen den Widerspruch der FDP und des
bundesjustizministers ich möchte dass
die Bundesregierung klarstellt dass
diese Möglichkeit der Strafverfolgung
über die sogenannten IP-Adressen nach
der Entscheidung des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs vom heutigen Tag
wahrgenommen wird und dass wir in diesem
zivilisierten Land dafür sorgen dass
diese ich muss es so sagen wie ich es
empfinde diese ekelhaften Straftaten
dass diese Strafverfolgung jetzt mit
diesem Mittel auch ermöglicht wird ich
habe überhaupt kein Verständnis dafür
dass ein Bundesjustizminister der der
FDP angehört dieses Mittel jetzt erneut
nicht anwenden muss möchte das ist ein
strafrechtliches verfolgungsmittel das
sich für unseren Rechtsstaat und auch
für unsere zivilisierte Gesellschaft
letztendlich auf der Hand liegt dass wir
es nutzen und ich möchte die Gelegenheit
auch wahrnehmen dies heute hier in aller
Klarheit zu sagen ich werde das auch
gleich noch in der Fraktionssitzung zum
Ausdruck bringen dass wir hier von der
Bundesregierung erwarten dass dieses
Mittel der Strafverfolgung jetzt genutzt
wird so wie der europäische Gerichtshof
das heute auch festgestellt hat vielen
Dank
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir
erleben eine neue
wirrwar-wende bei der gasumlage diese
Woche durch die ampelregierung
offensichtlich hat nach Presseberichten
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck intern
Zweifel an der rechtlichen Zulässigkeit
der Umlage geäußert das heißt dass nach
der schlampigen Planung der gasumlage
nach einer falschen Entscheidung bei der
Einführung dann einer zeitlichen
Verschiebung der Einführung jetzt auch
die neue Wende kommt rechtliche Zweifel
an der eigenen gasumlage
anzumelden wenn diese Zweifel oder wenn
sich bestätigt dass diese Zweifel
offensichtlich im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium vorhanden
sind dann gibt es diese Woche die
Gelegenheit die gasumlage sofort zu
stoppen wir haben den Antrag dazu im
deutschen Bundestag und werden die
Entscheidung dazu auch in dieser Woche
im Deutschen Bundestag
herbeiführen es wird sich zeigen ob der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister diese Zweifel
die er offensichtlich intern geäußert
hat dann auch im Bundestag so vorträgt
und die gasumlage dann sofort auch
gestoppt wird
also das die ampelregierung einem
Gesetzentwurf der Oppositionsfraktion
cdu/csu zustimmt am Donnerstag das ist
mehr als unwahrscheinlich aber sie haben
die beiden Herren von der Opposition
gehört es sind Hochzeiten für
Oppositionspolitiker denn es gibt viele
Probleme die die Ampel sich teilweise
selbst bereitet und das ist natürlich
dann ein gefundenes Fressen um die Ampel
zu kritisieren Rolf Mütze nicht der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der SPD hat darauf
hingewiesen dass am kommenden Montag ein
Jahr ist her ist dass die Deutschen ein
Bundestag gewählt haben herauskam ein
Sozialdemokrat als Kanzler und Olaf das
hat ja versprochen dass er Führung
ausüben will wer Führung bestellt
bekommt sie auch hat er gesagt und in
der Tat heute kann der Kanzler hier
nicht eingreifen denn der wird heute
Abend heute Nacht genauer gesagt vor den
Vereinten Nationen reden das hat Rolf
Mütze nicht auch noch mal herausgestellt
aber sie haben ja die Opposition gehört
man erwartet schon dass die Ampel sich
jetzt mal in so grundlegenden Sachen wie
zum Beispiel bei der gasumlage einig
wird mal sehen ob das diese Woche der
Fall ist in der kommenden Woche
jedenfalls ist der ganze auch schwer
beschäftigt da hat er nämlich die
Ministerpräsidenten zur Gast die wenig
im News sind über das dritte
Entlastungspaket wo sie plötzlich auch
finanziell gefordert sind da ging es an
und für sich nichts einzuwenden sagen
viele aber dass wir gar nicht gefragt
wurden das geht so nicht viele Probleme
also auch für die SPD aber Rolf Mütze
nicht ist grundsätzlich optimistisch was
die Zukunft angeht
wichtige Beratung in den nächsten
Sitzungswochen angesetzt aber ich würde
gerne am Anfang darauf aufmerksam machen
manchmal entfällt einem das in dieser
schnelllebigen Zeit dass wir gerade mal
vor einem Jahr am kommenden Montag hier
sich das eine Bundestagswahl hatten aus
der Olaf Scholz als Kanzler und die SPD
als stärkste Regierungsfraktion
hervorgegangen sind
cdu/csu in die Opposition geschickt
worden und so wollen wir es weiter in
dieser Legislaturperiode auch halten
dass wir mit einem guten Kanzler und mit
einer starken Fraktion letztlich auch
die Geschicke in diesem Land werden
bestimmen wollen und das wird sich ja
auch in dieser Woche durch noch mal
halten in einer Situation wo unser Land
vor großen Herausforderungen steht und
wir werden unter anderem in dieser
Sitzungswoche wiederum entlastungspakete
auf den Weg bringen die verabredet
worden sind unter anderem zur kalten
Progression unter anderem zur Absenkung
der gegensatzsteuer beim Gas uns dann
eben auch noch andere Bereiche die davon
betroffen sind und das wird auch in den
nächsten Wochen der Fall sein umso
überraster war ich gewesen weil das
insgesamt drei große Pakete bisher
gewesen sind über 100 Milliarden Euro wo
sich an den beiden ersten auch die
Länder beteiligt haben dass sich sowohl
der Ministerpräsident Söder als auch
Kretschmer beide aus unterschiedlichen
Parteien aber oft im gemeinsamen
Auftreten in den letzten Monaten sehr
deutlich gemacht haben dass sie sich
eigentlich gar nicht an dieser
Entlastung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
beteiligen möchten und deswegen werden
wir auf der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dies auch
noch mal erfragen die Länder haben ein
hohes Steueraufkommen sie sind auch
gegenüber ihren Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
in der Pflicht aber ich finde das ist
auch eine gesamtstaatliche Aufgabe dass
die Sorgen den Menschen genommen werden
sollen und das haben wir im
Koalitionsausschuss auch so beraten zum
Schluss würde ich gerne darauf
aufmerksam machen das war jetzt noch
glaube ich relativ früh am Morgen in New
York ist aber trotzdem heute Abend der
Bundeskanzler doch bei der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen eine Rede für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland halten wird
ein sozialdemokratischer Bundeskanzler
vor der Generalversammlung sozusagen vor
dem weltparlaments das ist für uns ein
wichtiges Ereignis und unterstreicht
noch mal das was ich auch am Anfang
gesagt habe dass wir gut
in den Händen einer Bundesregierung und
eines Bundeskanzlers und einer
Regierungsmehrheit sind und das auf der
anderen Seite auch die Erfordernisse die
die Welt an uns stellt derzeit in New
York beraten werden und das doch der
Bundeskanzler eine Rede erhält macht uns
sehr stolz vielen Dank dann kommen wir
zu den Fragen erste Frau Konert
die SPD fordert ja schon seit längerem
oder kritisiert ihr Fehler an der
gasumlage was fordern Sie stattdessen
und es gibt ja auch Berichte dass
Juniper jetzt verstaatlicht wird ist das
vereinbar mit einer gasumlage nun wir
werden uns das nochmal jetzt genau
anschauen möglicherweise werden wir ja
bereits in der nächsten Woche die
zweiten und dritten Lesung auch dazu
haben wir werden uns aber auch noch mal
sehr stark rechtlich damit befassen wenn
ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe ist
am Freitag auch noch mal eine Anhörung
zu diesen Fragen wo wir auch mit
Expertinnen und Experten beraten werden
und die Schlussfolgerung werden wir dann
auch in den nächsten Tagen ziehen
Herr Rinke
der anknüpfend noch mal nachgefragt das
heißt die gasumlage an der wollen sie
festhalten weil ja offenbar Zweifel in
der Koalition und bei Herrn Habeck laut
geworden sind ob das jetzt wirklich noch
der richtige Weg ist wenn man uniper
anders helfen muss und jetzt meine
eigentliche Frage zum Entlastungspaket
es gibt schon drohende Union dass das im
Bundesrat auf jeden Fall blockiert würde
und in den Vermittlungsausschuss muss
ist das auch ihre Erwartung nun ich habe
ja eben schon mal darauf hingewiesen
wenn der Wirtschaftsminister nach dem
offensichtlich und das hat er ja selbst
bedauert in seinem Haus und durch ihn
selbst die gasumlage vielleicht nicht
doch die
letztlich auch guten Schliff und auch
rechtlichen Schliffe gehabt hat dass man
hier nacharbeiten muss werden wir uns
natürlich auch seine Expertise anhören
wir haben eine eigene Expertise und
werden die auch mit Expertinnen und
Experten auch noch mal in der Anhörung
beleuchten und dann werden wir auch zu
entsprechenden schlussfolgung innerhalb
der Koalition kommen für die weiteren
Beratung und was sie im Hinblick auf den
Bundesrat gesagt haben ich bin
eigentlich sehr zuversichtlich dass
gerade die sozialdemokratischen
Ministerpräsidentin Ministerpräsidenten
ihrer Verantwortung für das was Menschen
zurzeit sehr stark um sorgt nämlich die
Steigerung der Energiepreise aber auch
der Verbraucherpreise insgesamt auch
durch Hilfen beantwortet werden diese
Ministerpräsidenten sehen das auch als
gesamtstaatliche Aufgabe umso mehr
bedauere ich und deswegen habe ich das
ja auch am Anfang gesagt und dann gehen
auch noch mal dass sie das aufgenommen
haben warum gerade der bayerische
Ministerpräsident und der
baden-württembergische Ministerpräsident
hier Drohungen ausstoßen in Richtung
Berlin erschließt sich mir vor dem
Hintergrund der dramatischen Situation
überhaupt nicht die Länder waren dazu
bisher in der Lage gewesen und sie
können auch zukünftig Herr Kollege
aldrup von Welt Fernsehen und zwar
sollte die gasumlage tatsächlich gekippt
werden würde dann auch die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung zurückgenommen
werden und wir werden ja jetzt in dieser
Woche die erste Lesung genau zu diesem
Bereich haben und beides
ist ja sozusagen auch in einem jung-team
auf den Weg gebracht worden
nachgearbeitet worden auch das wird dann
in unsere rechtliche und politische
Bewertung Einfluss nehmen und
entsprechende Entscheidung wenn wir dann
innerhalb der Koalition auch
herbeiführen
Rolf Mütze nicht sagte wenn das Gesetz
nicht so einen ganz guten Schliff hat
dann muss da noch mal nachgebessert
werden ein bemerkenswerter Satz da ging
es natürlich um die Frage gasumlage
dieses Gesetz ist von Anfang bis zum
Ende handwerklichen mooks das sagt
zumindest die Opposition Katharina dröge
ist eine der beiden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Bündnis grünen
Robert Habeck hat ja nun offensichtlich
auch selber Zweifel an dieser gasumlage
aber das lassen die Grünen nicht gelten
sie sind auf dem gesetzgebungsweg im
übrigen ist bei der jetzigen Situation
alles sehr schwierig aber man sei auf
einem guten Weg das gilt zum Beispiel
auch für das Gas was man schon
eingelagert hat von grüner Seite hört
man immer dieser Winter wird nicht
einfach werden der nächste der wird dann
viel leichter woher diese Erkenntnis
kommt weiß ich nicht sie haben es gehört
die Union z.B sie sagt ja die AKWs
müssen weiterlaufen auch noch im Winter
23 24 denn da gibt es kein russisches
Gas mehr aber das ist im Moment ganz gut
dass man zumindest Katharina dröge
es ist eine
gute Nacht die Robert Habeck hier
vorgenommen hat und es ist auch eine
gute Nachricht das ist jetzt gelungen
ist für das Unternehmen Rosneft und
damit mit Blick auf die Abhängigkeit von
russischen Öl eine Lösung zu finden und
rostenneft unter die Treuhand der
Bundesnetzagentur zu stellen zwei enorm
wichtige Schritte und diese Woche steht
im Deutschen Bundestag eine weitere
Reform des energiesicherheitsgesetzes an
mit der wir ernst machen bei einem
weiteren noch schnelleren Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien wir heben
kurzfristig alle Potenziale bei den
erneuerbaren Energien die man heben kann
das heißt die Decke müssen weg bei
solar- und Biomasse das runterregeln bei
Wind am Land wird abgeschafft und wir
machen sonderausschreibungen für das
Thema Solarenergie und wir als grüne
Bundestagsfraktion sagen das muss jetzt
schnell durch parlamentarische Verfahren
das muss dann auch in der nächsten
Sitzungswoche abgeschlossen werden da
werden wir innerhalb der Koalition
führen
Versorgungssicherheit heißt aber auch
dass wir mit besonderer Sorge auf ein
Bundesland schauen und das ist Bayern
denn wenn man sich anschaut warum Bayern
in Schwierigkeiten ist dann liegt es auf
der einen Seite an der Blockade des
netzausbaust durch viele Jahre
csu-regierung und es liegt auf der
anderen Seite am dramatischen Blockieren
der Windenergie und wir haben ein Wind
an Land gesetzt verabschiedet dass die
Bundesländer in die Pflicht nimmt aber
wir erkennen bei Bayern bislang
keinerlei Anstrengung ernst zu machen
mit dem Ausbau der Windenergie im
Gegenteil sie versuchen alles um darum
herum zu kommen die Windenergie
auszubauen die ausbauzahlen in Bayern
sind dramatisch und sie werden wenn man
sich das angemeldete anschaut auch nicht
besser hier kann man der bayerischen
Landesregierung nur sagen wenn ihr den
Wirtschaftsstandort Bayern nicht
gefährden wollt dann macht ihr endlich
ernst
unter dem Problem die in Bayern liegen
kommt jetzt auch noch ein Problem mit
dem Thema Atomenergie Markus Söder ist
nicht müde geworden in den letzten
Wochen immer dafür zu werben dass das
Atomkraftwerk Isa 2 weiterlaufen soll
gemeinsam mit
dem Betreiber E.ON haben sie versprochen
dieses Atomkraftwerk steht jederzeit zur
Verfügung um auch über den Winter hinaus
weiterzulaufen wir sehen jetzt dass das
so nicht stimmt das Reparaturen am
Atomkraftwerk notwendig sind und die
Frage stellt sich schon wann wussten die
Betreiber eigentlich davon dass dieser
Reparaturbedarf notwendig ist wann
wusste auch die bayerische
Landesregierung und die bayerische
Atomaufsicht davon dass diese
Reparaturbedarf notwendig ist und warum
haben Sie gegebenenfalls diese
Informationen nicht früher zur Verfügung
gestellt das gehört zu einer
verantwortungsvollen Politik dazu gerade
wenn es um eine hochrisikotechnologie
wie die Atomkraft geht Umlage
wie ist die Position der Grünen dazu
jetzt auch vor dem Hintergrund der
uniper verstattlichung
ist aus unserer Sicht sehr wichtig dass
wir am Ende Maßnahmen beschließen die
den Gasmarkt stabilisieren die die
Versorgung der Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher mit Gas gewährleisten und
insbesondere auch die Stadtwerke an
dieser Stelle stabilisieren wir haben
als Deutscher Bundestag der
Bundesregierung mit dem
energiesicherheitsgesetz verschiedene
Optionen zur Verfügung gestellt und die
Bundesregierung hat sich dazu
entschlossen den Weg der Umlage zu gehen
das ist eine Maßnahme die gerechter ist
als alleine die Preise auf die Kunden
von Juniper umzulegen weil mehr
gasgründen solidarisch diese Preise
Schultern die sonst alleine den Kunden
von uniper aufgelastet worden wären ich
höre dass die Bundesregierung das
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck jetzt einen
guten Weg gefunden hat mit der
Europäischen Kommission das Problem der
Trittbrettfahrer zu lösen das heißt
diejenigen Unternehmen von der Umlage
auszuschließen die profitabel sind und
damit diese Unterstützung auch nicht
brauchen das sind gute Nachrichten und
konnte sich die Rechtsnatur der
Unternehmen ändern die von dieser Umlage
profitieren dann ist es natürlich so
dass man auch die Rechtsnatur der Umlage
noch einmal bewerten muss auch meine
Frage nochmal die Nachfrage das heißt
wenn es jetzt eine Verstaatlichung von
Juniper geben würde dann würde keine
Gasanlage kommen
also noch sind wir da nicht so das heißt
wir müssen uns anschauen wie sich die
Rechtsnatur der Unternehmen entwickelt
ob dort ein stärkerer staatlicher Anteil
notwendig wird wir wissen dass sich die
Situation auf den gastmärkten
verschlechtert hat dadurch dass kein Gas
mehr durch den ostream 1 geleitet wird
und wir davon ausgehen müssen dass das
auch erstmal so bleibt gleichzeitig die
Preise explodieren auf den Gasmärkten
und das macht wahrscheinlich einen
zusätzlichen stabilisierungsbedarf für
diese Unternehmen notwendig und ich bin
sicher dass die Bundesregierung dort
auch an Lösungen arbeitet wenn es Fragen
gibt zur Umlage dann bin ich mir sicher
dass insbesondere das Finanzministerium
dass wir die Kompetenz für
finanzverfassungsrechtliche Fragen hat
dieses sehr genau prüfen wird nochmal
klarzustellen also ich habe aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium eben gehört dass
die gasumlage erstmal kommt aber
möglicherweise die Unternehmen wenn
feststeht welche Unternehmen sie erheben
dürfen das erst im November rückwirkend
für Oktober waren also verlangen
wenn ich sie so höre ist das ja fraglich
ob die gasumlage überhaupt kommt oder
können Sie das noch mal klarstellen
bitte
also die genauen Zeitpläne macht die
Regierung und muss die an dieser Stelle
auch beantworten die Arbeiten jetzt so
schnell sie können da habe ich großes
Vertrauen in die Regierung sie haben
jetzt erstmal angekündigt dass die
Umlage um einen Monat verschoben wird
und so wie ich das sehe sind jetzt
zumindest die Fragen mit Blick auf die
Trittbrettfahrer soweit gelöst mit Blick
auf die Frage was das jetzt bedeutet
falls Unternehmen eine andere
Rechtsnatur bekommen sollten wird es mit
Sicherheitsprüfung des
Finanzministeriums geben
tja die Rechtsnatur daran kann es
natürlich liegen aber so richtig blickt
hier auch keiner mehr durch was die
gasumlage angeht ich versuche es mal zu
sortieren also die Bundesregierung oder
Teile der Bundesregierung sage ich mal
lieber vorsichtig arbeiten daran dass
diese gasumlage so kommt wie sie
beschlossen ist mit Einschränkungen zum
Beispiel Energieunternehmen die Gewinn
machen dürfen dann diese gasumlage
hinterher nicht bekommen die den Erlös
aus der gasumlage aber es kann auch gut
sein dass man in dieser oder der
kommenden Woche sich darauf einigen muss
dass dieses Gesetz einfach gar nicht
stattfinden kann weil zum Beispiel die
rechtsvoraussetzungen sich geändert
haben der
FDP-Fraktionsvorsitzende dürr ist ja der
Meinung dass bei der jetzigen
Energiekrise alles getan werden muss
damit die Wärme auch nach Hause kommen
kann bzw der Strom nicht ausgeht und
deswegen ist ja der Meinung dass sie die
zwei Kohlekraftwerke die bisher ins Netz
gegangen sind zu wenig sind es müssen
die drei atomkraft hier länger laufen
und auf unseren Nachfrage weil er das
fast jeden Dienstag hier sagt hat er
geantwortet naja warten wir erstmal den
Parteitag der Grünen am 9 oktober ab
danach erwartet er hier im Deutschen
Bundestag in dieser Frage eine
Abstimmung der Gesetzgeber muss auf
vieles Rücksicht nehmen aber die Zeit
die läuft und Christian dürr war aber
ansonsten der Meinung dass die Maßnahmen
die man bisher getroffen hat sehr wohl
ausreichen um diesen Winter einigermaßen
in den Griff zu bekommen
die Lage am Energiemarkt in Deutschland
ist leider dramatisch die hohen
Gaskosten lassen auch die Strompreise
weiter in die Höhe schnellen wir erleben
bei den Strompreisen teilweise eine
20-fachung des Preises das sind Preise
die sich kein privater Haushalt kein
mittelständisches Unternehmen leisten
kann und deswegen sind wir in der
Pflicht das zu ändern wir haben ja im
Koalitionsausschuss vor einiger Zeit
dazu weitreichende Beschlüsse gefasst
ich denke beispielsweise an die
strompreisbremse von der ich sage sie
muss so schnell wie möglich auch
national umgesetzt werden denn wir sind
in europäischer Ebene zwar im Gespräch
aber ich habe nicht die Hoffnung dass
von europäischer Ebene sehr schnell eine
Lösung kommt deswegen sollten wir eine
nationale Lösung anstreben die
strompreisbremse ist das richtige
Instrument und sie muss schnellstmöglich
umgesetzt werden wir haben weiterhin
beschlossen auch steuerliche
Entlastungsmaßnahmen der Vorschlag des
Bundesfinanzministers für einen
Inflationsausgleich bei der
Einkommensteuer das betrifft 48
Millionen
einkommensteuerzahlerinnen
einkommensteuerzahler in Deutschland der
wird in dieser Woche in den Deutschen
Bundestag gehen wir werden also eine
erste Lesung dieses Gesetzes haben
genauso wie wir die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas in den
Deutschen Bundestag bringen also der
Bundesfinanzminister hat hier bereits
Vorarbeit geleistet diese wichtigen
Teile des entlastungspaketes 3 gehen
jetzt bereits in die parlamentarische
Beratung es braucht mehr bezahlbaren und
mehr sicheren Strom in Deutschland und
das müssen wir entsprechend an den Markt
bringen bei den Erneuerbaren hat ja die
Ampelkoalition schon einiges beschlossen
ich denke an das osterpaket
beispielsweise an dieser Stelle will ich
betonen dabei geht es mitnichten nur um
Stromproduktion erneuerbare
Stromproduktion an Land sondern
insbesondere das Thema offshore müssen
wir voranbringen das ist eine sichere
und stetige Energiequelle in der Zukunft
und gerade wenn wir über den hinaus den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren nachdenken wird
offshore Windenergie eine ganz
entscheidende Rolle spielen aber das ist
etwas was natürlich nicht kurzfristig
wirkt deswegen müssen wir insbesondere
über die Energieversorgung in den
kommenden zwei Wintern sprechen und die
Energieversorgung im Winter die darf
nicht vom Wetter abhängen das ist glaube
ich ein wichtiger Punkt im Zusammenhang
mit dem Thema Erdgas will ich auf einen
Punkt noch zu sprechen komme ich sagte
vorhin dass wir die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Erdgas diese
Woche in den Deutschen Bundestag bringen
ich war sehr überrascht über die
Äußerung der Union die jetzt sagt es
dürfen auf gar keinen Fall eine
gasumlage geben ich frage mich nachdem
die Union in den letzten Jahren
Regierungsverantwortung getragen hat und
auch eine Mitverantwortung für die
aktuelle
energiepolitische Situation in
Deutschland trägt weil sie sich hat
abhängig machen lassen von russischem
Erdgas ich frage mich was die
Alternativvorschläge der CDU und CSU
sind ich höre bisher etwas von einem
Deckel da stellt sich die Frage wie das
finanziert werden soll ginge nur über
einen Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse das
kann eigentlich auch für die Union nicht
akzeptabel sein es werden andere Dinge
gerade für den Gasmarkt auf europäischer
Ebene diskutiert und besprochen
beispielsweise der Großeinkauf von von
Erdgas mit dem Ziel dass die Preise für
die Verbraucher und Verbraucher und für
die Unternehmen in Europa tragbar sind
das setzt voraus europäische Solidarität
und das heißt eben auch dass Deutschland
von sich aus alles tun muss um dieser
europäischen Solidarität gerecht zu
werden und der erste Punkt in dem
Zusammenhang was können wir selbst tun
in Deutschland ist sicherlich auch bei
den bisherigen Kraftwerkskapazitäten
anzusetzen da ist zum einen das Thema
Kohle zu nennen wir wollen eine
Entscheidung um das Angebot auszuweiten
wir haben diese Grundsatzentscheidung
vor der Sommerpause bereits getroffen
nämlich die vorübergehende Rückkehr der
Kohlekraftwerke in Deutschland ans Netz
die wieder Ausnahme des Betriebes
einiger Kraftwerke lohnt sich allerdings
für die Betreiber derzeit nicht
ausreichend bisher erst zwei Kraftwerke
wieder ans Netz gegangen das wird nicht
ausreichen um die Preise so zu senken
wie es entsprechend nötig ist ein
zweiter wichtiger Energieträger derzeit
noch in Deutschland ist auch die
Kernenergie sie ist grundlastfähig sie
ist sogar regelfähig als Energie und sie
wissen dass ich aus Niedersachsen komme
bin derzeit sehr viel im Land unterwegs
und es vergeht kein einziger Tag wo mich
nicht Unternehmerin Unternehmer die
Menschen ansprechen welche Nöte sie
haben angesichts der steigenden
Energiekosten von denen ich vorhin
bereits sprach und deswegen ist auch
mein fester Eindruck aus vielen
Gesprächen dass die Zustimmung der
Menschen in Deutschland der Unternehmen
in Deutschland für eine
Laufzeitverlängerung der noch drei der
der drei noch am Netz befindlichen
Kernkraftwerke enorm hoch ist und
schließen Sie die Rücknahme der
gasumlage als F Fraktion jetzt aus oder
nicht es ist ja ein Vorstand des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers insofern wer
die Frage an ihn zu stellen gasumlage
ist ja nicht unser Vorschlag gewesen
auch kein parlamentarischer Vorschlag
sondern regierungsseitig durch das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium insofern
ist das zu beantworten
so als Fraktion sie müssten ja im
Bundestag zustimmen oder auch nicht ja
also eine gasumlage die so gemacht ist
dass sie die Preise senkt und dass sie
vernünftig funktioniert ist gut wenn das
nicht der Fall ist da muss man aber ein
anderes Instrument finden was nicht
ausreichen wird ist nichts zu tun das
wird nicht gehen sondern wir brauchen
hier auch nationales handeln
ja aber die FDP sitzt bekanntlich mit in
der Ampel und das nichts tun liegt ja
auch daran dass man eben offensichtlich
dann den Partner nicht widerspricht
jedenfalls Robert Habeck hat jetzt das
Heft des Handelns in die Hand genommen
hat gesagt wir müssen dann noch mal
gucken ob das überhaupt alles so
rechtens ist mit der gasumlage meine
Damen und Herren ich kann Ihnen immer
noch nicht sagen wie das ausgeht die AFD
hat heute Fraktionssitzung Alice Weidel
und Tino krupala sind Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzender haben sich wie
immer auch vor ihrer Sitzung geäußert
tja herzlich willkommen zu unserem
wöchentlichen Pressegespräch
Deutschland darf keine Kampfpanzer
liefern es ist eine gute Tradition der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in kriegs-
und das ist auch im übrigen der Grund
warum kein anderes nato-land
Panzer
liefert und da muss man sich die Frage
stellen warum das so ist offensichtlich
haben andere NATO-Staaten die Kanäle
noch offen und wissen genau wo die roten
Linien sind
und die roten Linien sind bei offensiv
Waffensystemen
Deutschland muss unbedingt dafür sorgen
diese Bundesregierung der Bundeskanzler
als auch die Außenministerin müssen
unbedingt dafür sorgen dass dieser
Konflikt nicht weiter eskaliert
denn wir laufen Gefahr in
unkontrollierte Prozesse hineinzulaufen
die in eine kriegerische
Auseinandersetzung führen können das
NATO-Staaten mit Russland
aneinandergeraten und warum das eine
schlechte Idee ist das kann jeder für
sich beantworten
beide Verbände
haben Nuklearwaffen
und das ist der Grund dass wir unseren
Beitrag dazu leisten keine
offensivwaffensysteme keine Panzer
keinen Leopard und keinen Marder in die
Ukraine zu liefern das machen die
anderen Staaten auch nicht sondern uns
anzustrengen eine friedliche Lösung so
schnell wie möglich einen
Friedensvertrag herbeizuführen
vielen Dank
ich möchte vielleicht auf einige Punkte
auch der plenumswoche unserer Fraktion
eingehen auch auf unseren Antrag den wir
diese Woche am Donnerstag vorstellen
werden was die Laufzeitverlängerung der
Kernkraftwerke angeht wir sehen
insgesamt dass die wirtschaftliche Lage
in Deutschland immer bedrohlicher wird
dass die Bürger mit wachsender Sorge
immer mehr auf die nächsten Wochen und
Monate schauen dass die Inflationsrate
auch im August 2022 nahe acht Prozent
liegt im Vergleich zum Vorjahresmonat
und dass das Ifo-Institut auch für
nächstes Jahr schon prognostiziert hat
eine Inflationsrate von neun Prozent der
Höchststand wird im nächsten Jahr im
Frühjahr erwartet von 13% Inflationsrate
also dieses Spirale wird weitergehen und
ist eben noch nicht durchbrochen die
allgemeine Inflationsrate allein durch
die Erzeugerpreise die explodierenden
Preise auf die Erzeugerpreise liegt bei
37 Prozent auch das trägt ja weiter dazu
bei dass diese Rate steigt also diese
akute Gefahr auch in Deutschland die wir
durch diese Preisentwicklung sehen
gerade Botschaft bei Mittelstand der
dehnustrialisierung im internationalen
Vergleich zum Beispiel mit der USA wo
wir einen neuen Fach höheren Gaspreis
mittlerweile haben was natürlich auch
zur Wettbewerbsverzerrung führt und
natürlich auch die Wirtschaft in
existenziellen not führen wird deshalb
muss die Bundesregierung hier endlich
eine Strategie vorlegen wie sie dem
entgegen geht bislang sehen wir aktuell
dass die Bundesregierung hier nur auf
Sicht fährt haha Beck diskutierten
überlegt jetzt die gasumlage wieder
abzuschaffen also in welcher Form auch
immer es gibt keine klare Strategie der
Bundesregierung man will im Moment auch
die Autonomie in Energieversorgung durch
die Abschottung vom Markt erzielen und
genau das ist unsere Auffassung auch der
falsche Weg die Isolation ist der
falsche Weg sie zerstört unser Land die
gefährdet unsere Wirtschaften auch
unsere Bürger und deshalb muss es hier
auch diese Lösung der sanktionsaufhebung
nur geben damit unsere Bürger entlastet
werden damit auch unsere Wirtschaft
wieder atmen kann und auch hier
gesichert nicht nur über die nächsten
Winter sondern über den nächsten zwei
drei Jahre auch kommen kann und es gibt
ja mittlerweile immer mehr sorgen auch
von ifo-instituten von Handwerkskammern
von Verbänden auch der
Wohnungswirtschaft die uns alle jeden
Tag schreiben und zukommen die darauf
hinweisen wie existenziell schwierig die
Lage aktuell ist fast alle Betriebe ja
meine Damen und Herren da muss man ein
bisschen härter herausgeben denn es
bleibt noch eine Fraktion Die Linke und
da ist heute richtig viel los und viele
erwarten einen Showdown denn es gibt
acht Fraktionsmitglieder die einen
Antrag stellen werden das Sarah
Wagenknecht sich entweder an die Linie
der Fraktion der parteizuhalten hat oder
aber nicht mehr als Rednerin aufgestellt
werden darf sie erinnern sich vielleicht
sie hat am 8 September gesprochen als
einzige Rednerin für die Linke von
Wirtschaftskrieg des Westens gesprochen
und daraufhin sind Fabio demasi der
ehemalige Bundestagsabgeordnete und auch
Ulrich Schneider der Chef des
Paritätischen Wohlfahrtsverbandes aus
der linken ausgetreten und viele sind
sauer auf Sarah Wagenknecht das ist
nichts neues das hat bei den Linken
immer schon gegeben es gibt einen
entscheidenden Unterschied zu früher
seit Legislaturperiode ist die Linke ja
mit nur ganz wenig Abgeordneten 39
vertreten und sollten drei die Fraktions
verlassen dann ist man gar keine
Fraktionsgemeinschaft mehr und das wäre
bitter weniger Geld weniger Einfluss das
will keiner deswegen ist der
Fraktionsspitze so ein bisschen das Heft
des Handelns aus der Hand genommen und
man darf gespannt sein wie die heutige
Fraktionssitzung endet Amira [ __ ] mit
Ali ist die Fraktionsvorsitzende und sie
hat sich zunächst auf die anderen Themen
des der Diskussion konzentriert
die Preise explodieren weiterhin viele
Menschen bekommen jetzt in diesen Tagen
die Briefe von ihren Energieversorgern
die eine deutlich höhere Vorauszahlung
von Ihnen fordern der Wocheneinkauf wird
teurer und teurer und man muss sagen was
die Bundesregierung dagegen tut ist
absolut ungenügend und die Kommunikation
ist auch wirklich mehr als ein Desaster
ich habe mich in der Vergangenheit schon
häufiger geäußert es soll mal zum
ungenügenden entlastungspaketen das ist
bleibt die Wahrheit 300 Euro
Einmalzahlung ist einfach viel zu wenig
ein möglicherweise irgendwann kommen der
strompreisdeckel geknüpft an eine
undefinierte
zufallsgewinnen Abschöpfung auf EU-Ebene
das reicht überhaupt nicht aus nein die
Menschen brauchen jetzt Entlastung die
Menschen brauchen einen
energiepreisdeckel wir werden in dieser
Woche auch das Thema
gaspreisdeckel ansprechen in der
Fraktionen dazu einen Antrag vorbereiten
Minister Habeck hat so Energieversorgung
gesagt wenn wir gut durch den Winter wir
würden gut durch den Winter kommen wenn
das Wetter mitspielt und das finde ich
schon in der erschreckende Äußerung denn
es kann doch jetzt nicht davon abhängen
dass wir Glück haben und einen milden
Winter erleben ob die Energieversorgung
der Bevölkerung ob die sichergestellt
ist ob das ausreicht nein da erwarte ich
wirklich mehr ich erwarte dass die
Bundesregierung alles unternimmt um die
Energieversorgung sicherzustellen und
eben auch sich dafür einzusetzen dass
wir bezahlbare Energie haben natürlich
ist es so dass man die Ursache nicht
vergessen darf die dazu geführt hat dass
die Preise steigen das ist der
schreckliche Krieg in der Ukraine aber
wir sehen eben auch das andere Länder
die auch mit dieser Situation klarkommen
müssen da wesentlich bessere Lösungen
gefunden haben Deutschland ist
Strompreis Weltmeister das ist wirklich
ein zweifelhafte Ehre ein zwei ist der
Titel andere Länder im europäischen
Ausland oder auch in der Welt haben das
ganz anders geregelt ich will nur mal
ein Beispiel sagen in Deutschland ist
der Gaspreis achtmal so hoch für die
Industrie wie zum Beispiel in den USA in
Nachbarstaaten ist Benzin Diesel
wesentlich billiger andere Länder
Frankreich haben strompreisdeckel
eingeführt das müsste längst geschehen
es geht nicht dass die Verbraucher eine
Verbraucher im Regen stehen gelassen
werden und jetzt sagt der Robert Habeck
dass er Zweifel hat an der
verfassungsgruppen
gasumlage finanzverfassungsrechtliche
Bedenken hat er ja guten Morgen wir
haben schon länger verfassungsrechtliche
Bedenken an der gasumlage angemeldet
weil in der Tat ist es
unserer Ansicht nach wirklich mehr als
zweifelhaft ob ein System nach dem alle
die Gas
abnehmen müssen unabhängig von der Frage
ob sich dafür entscheiden können oder
nicht weil ich eben nicht entscheiden
kann wie meine Wohnung beheizt wird dass
die müssen zahlen und das den Erlös
davon bekommen Konzerne die unter
anderem auch unter Umständen auch große
Gewinne gemacht haben dass das ich sag
mal verfassungsrechtlich ein Problem
sein könnte darauf war haben wir schon
länger gewarnt jetzt wird das ganze von
Robert Habeck verschoben
an Christian Lindner ja also das ist
alles ziemlicher Blödsinn die gasumlage
von diesen Vorhaben muss man sich jetzt
verabschieden es ist der falsche Weg
stattdessen ist es richtig die
Energieversorger die Stadtwerke die
Unterstützung brauchen die müssen
unterstützt werden und dieser Murks dass
man das allen gaskundinnen und Kunden
überhelfen möchte und dann am Ende noch
an Unternehmen ich sag mal so man
auszahlt die überhaupt keine Hilfe
brauchen das ist einfach völliger
Blödsinn und es ist unzumutbar und es
ist einfach also ich möchte mal sagen
eine eine brachiale Frechheit
prominente Parteiaustritte aus ihrer
Partei gegeben nach der Rede von Sarah
wagenknechte wie sehen sie ihre eigene
Verantwortung dafür dass Sahra
Wagenknecht mit einer absoluten
Minderheitsmeinung bei der Linken
zumindest Fraktion als einzige Rednerin
bei dieser Debatte aufgestellt wurde
denn sie sind ja eigentlich dafür
verantwortlich als Fraktionschefin
ich möchte
so in einer Deutlichkeit sagen ich
bedauere das wenn Mitglieder austreten
ich bedaure dass bei jedem einzelnen
Mitglied das austritt und ich
ja ich finde das ist immer ein Verlust
nun haben wir gesehen dass es Austritte
gibt in unserer Partei aus verschiedenen
Gründen sag mal gerade um dieses Thema
Umgang mit Sahra Wagenknecht gibt es
beide Bewegungen die einen sind der
Auffassung man müsste jetzt Sarah
Wagenknecht mehr Regeln vorgeben und die
anderen sind der Meinung Sarah
Wagenknecht wird schlecht behandelt aus
beiden Gründen treten Mitglieder unserer
Partei aus das ist eine Situation die
hochbrisant ist und mit der wir umgehen
müssen und wir werden in der Fraktion
darüber debattieren ja meine Situation
die in der Linksfraktion gar nicht so
neu ist aber ich habe es vorhin erwähnt
sie ist deshalb prekär weil die
Linksfraktion ja nur hier in den
Deutschen Bundestag eingezogen ist weil
man drei Direktmandate erhalten hat und
sollten jetzt drei Abgeordnete hier
austreten dann wäre der Fraktionsstatus
also das dürfte spannend werden wie das
heute ausgeht die gasumlage keiner weiß
genau ist hier aus Berlin und damit geht
es weiter mit unserem Programm in Bonn
mit Bernd rase
danke schön Gerd Joachim von verloren in
Berlin ja und ich weise noch mal auf die
Sendung der Tag Phoenix der Tag um 17
Uhr hin da geht es unter anderem auch um
die Vollversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen in New York und natürlich um
das Urteil des EuGH zum Thema
Vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt sehen Sie
hier bei uns ein Phoenix plus eine
Reportage Flut moodwood ein Jahr nach
der Katastrophe meine Kolleginnen Mona
Heck und Inges Wollek haben sich noch
einmal im Ahrtal umgeschaut
[Musik]
die Freiheitsstatue das Symbol
schlechthin für die Vereinigten Staaten
von Amer